سلسله من التصريحات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تتراوح بين التحذير والتهديد يا
بيان القوات المسلحه مؤكدا على التزامهم
بالاتفاق لطري وحرصهم على حكومه مدنيه
وساخرا من المزايدين على مواقف الجيش تؤكد
قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه
قوات الدعم السريع ترى ان اساس الخلاف بين
من يريدون تسليم السلطه للمدنيين وبين
الذين يتمسكون بعدم ترك الحكم نافيه
خلافها مع القوات المسلحه
الناس اللي قاعدين مكنكشين والناس الدارين
يسلموا السلطه للحكومه المدنيه
في الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه اجواء التوتر
واصدم مخاوف من انزلاق للمواجهه يقلل
الخبراء من هذا الخلاف العسكري الخلاف
العسكري العسكري الذي برز في الساحه من
ايام الماضيه هو خلاف مجمل سياسي وخرج الى
الهواء الطلق من خلال التصريحات ولم يصل
الى القواعد العسكريه سواء كان في القوات
المسلحه او الدعم السريع وفي تقدير مثل ما
بدا صراع سياسي سينتهي صراع سياسي هذا
الصراع السياسي يمكن ان يقرا في طريقه
تنفيذ الاتفاق الايطالي واداره الفتره
الانتقاليه مساله الدمج الجيوش هي واحده
من المقلقات المخاوف بين الرجلين فالحل
ينبغي ان يكون هو الحوار الشفاف واخراج
الهواء الساخن ووضع الحلول التي لا تفضي
الى تعزيم التصعيد العسكري وهذا ما لا
يتمناه الجميع خلال الفتره المقبله
الاوضاعوا في الشوارع تبدو طبيعيه هادئه
فيما تتحدث تقارير عن توتر مكتوم بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ما دفع الكثير من
القوى السياسيه لابداء القلق على البلاد
سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم